[Musique]
dis moi que je fait kidnapper par année
plutôt une sorte de kidnapping ou sa
première expérience avec des
transformers entre les deux on va dire
vous pouvez foncer direct à buckingham
palace
ok vous le mâle américain on se tait
[Musique]
vous avez plus d'importance que vous
sauriez l'imaginer
l'un des plus grands mystères de tous
les temps
ça va
[Musique]
c'est votre destin depuis toujours
si tu es moi non
vous faites quoi demain à les embarquer
[Musique]
transformers2 last night
se prépare un truc qui se réglera poids
coq flingue
ce que vous avez connu dans la vie
ce n'était qu'un voyage vers ce moment
précis
transformers2 last night